find it that bad what is that a
xylophone what is that a harp celebrate
it boy
celebrate that misery boy daddy's down
well daddy's gonna dance get that hitter
Wow let's have some fun while we all D
why II and I think they're talking about
Easter eggs you know they're talking
about let's all have some fun while we
all die these eggs I'm joking man it's
not even that's wrong season if you come
in at Easter boy if you're trying to put
your mouth around a chocolate rabbit boy
you'd be hidden you are being naughty
you know dude they said this drawing our
neighborhood at Easter would get them
chocolate rabbits and put the whole
thing in her mouth and down her throat
and everything and it was I'm like I
don't know she would even bite into it
I'm like I don't think that's that's uh
Jesus ain't coming back for that you
know Jesus ain't coming back for that
for this dark magic but yes she was wild
dude and she never really developed
breasts was just I had a big round chest
kind of with nipples on the front and
that was just sort of who she was a real
kegerator of a girl thick neck - real
solid almost like a maple or mahogany
type of thick thick skin almost like her
foot like a full-body staph infection
that's how her thin her skin was just
thick all over you know like she was a
little bit of you know kind of skin and
something else in there like a light
quikrete you know like a light she was
sort of marbled kind of in a way anyhow
good to see you guys happy do sim but no
happy November - seven it is November -
seven can you believe it can you believe
it we made it this far
November 27 Monday's the year 2017 and
we are in the 64th shadow realm of the
universe make sure to get your to stock
up on turquoise that's a new reality
showing to be
turquoise hunters damn it Dale where'd
you put the map I don't know Noreen
but this turquoise hauling big enough
for the both of us could you even
imagine that being a damn turquoise
hunter just wait dude it's just to like
troubled people out in Tucson Arizona
just milling around a VFW or an American
Legion asking people for quartz and
turquoise turquoise hunters good to be
here with you guys man I hope you had a
wonderful weekend you know sometimes I
think about you know people listening to
this show and I wonder well what are
they doing you know I bet there's
somebody out there have a baby and they
taken their baby you know do wherever
babies go during the day to be away from
their families you know dropping them
off in the morning or maybe they're you
know I know we have a Red Bull truck
driver out there we got a male man out
there that listens they've called in we
got a man out there who drives a senior
citizen wagon you know sometime they
have the senior citizen adventure wagons
when senior citizens all because when
you get older you live together in a in
a special dorm or kind of a sorority
fraternity house with other seniors and
they have a wagon that will come and
pick something all up and take you to
the mall or to the park or sometimes
this dude said he called him one time
and said sometimes if he gets some of
the real incapacitated seniors he'll
just drive him around and tell him they
went to the mall you know or tell him
they went to Asia or somewhere you know
and make up some place that sounds
pretty fancy and he said a lot of their
Joy's just in getting out and about and
he said sometimes he'll even listen to
this podcast while he drives him around
so I think about that I think about well
who's who's listening you know you got
these I think about a little bus like a
small bus of or special wagon or you
know a very distinctive van which
hopefully I have windows on it there's
nothing real sadder to me than thinking
about a bunch of seniors in a van with
no windows I mean that's damn that's
Andy Dufresne type of stuff you know
that's prisoner that's prisoner
treatment
but I think about them listening to it
maybe they I know we have a couple of
Middle Eastern listeners and I think
about those guys listening to it out
there you know playing hacky sack or you
know collecting you know tall pieces of
grass to make things to sell on the side
of the road or I know we got I want you
you know laid up listeners handicapped
you know people that's you know in
disability and whatnot you know
wheelchairs you know you know people
that what are those little things those
Rascals people that ride Rascals I've
seen a couple of them at my comedy show
say that they're fans of the show so I
think about them and I just think about
the unique people you know the unique
plethora of humanity we got some mixed
people some brothers and some we've got
some ladies out there six percent of our
listeners are female so that's not very
many would love to have more but I had a
nice weekend man and I thought about you
guys a little bit I thought about you
guys and just who listens who listens to
this past weekend and I'm just trying to
you know come up with a little bit of
you know a little landscape a couple
shorties out there listen you know a
couple ladies I'll get some you know
I've gotten some pics on snapchat some
breasts and some individual breasts you
know which I prefer I never really trust
a woman to send you a picture of both
titties at the same time what is that
you know if you have two of something's
show one and if things are going well
show both that's what I've always said
if you have a pair of something you know
if you got two Buicks you don't show
somebody both Buicks at the same time
because what if you uh you know what if
they hate the first one you're sitting
there with another one [ __ ] but good
to be here man happy almost December
Thanksgiving is over I hope I went good
for you hopefully good for you you know
I hope you had that stuff in man I had
three Thanksgiving meals okay three you
know I had some white meat some turkey
and meat some long neck some sweet
potatoes with that marshmallow sauce
baby I baby I put them
Brown marshmallows on the top you know
had that hit you know I eat one meal
outside by candlelight by some cliffs
and this was out in the Hollywood Hills
and up by the cliffs and they had you
could even hear coyotes in the distance
I think it was coyotes could have been a
bear with a you know with a flute but it
sounded like a kind of a baritone flute
but it sounded like a coyote and what
else did we hear what else did we eat
not much else man had a friend's
birthday that was pretty cool where else
did I do uh thinking about having
another thinking about smoke I'm going
to days without smoking thinking am i
smoking dude swear to god bro I would
sack my own back if I knew there was
some nook on an act
I saw daddy's home - I'm if you ever
seen this movie I didn't even know there
was a first one
apparently daddy's home again it was
nice to see Mel Gibson and movie I like
Mel Gibson my favorite movie of all time
is the Patriot and also I like
Slingblade I used to date a girl who had
the same jawline of Sling Blade as the
man and then I also liked that movie
league of their own you know and some
people want to talk smack and I like
Armageddon you know saw like some pretty
bad movies also us but you're also
talking about Google a Goo Goo Dolls
listener you know you're also talking
about almost got molested in a mirror
and a bathroom and a Marilyn Manson show
you know you're also you're also talking
to a guy he used to do steroids on the
side of the interstate with a man that
looked like don flamenco from Mike
Tyson's punch-out and we ended up being
a homosexual gentleman and I remember
being over at his house and he was
crying about Princess Diana died and I
didn't know how Princess Diana was I
thought it was his dog I thought he had
a dog me and Princess Diana and I
remember trying to be sad and supportive
at the same time offering to get a
shovel dude I don't remember we were
high on marijuana I do remember that and
but then he years later he was doing
pills and drove into I'll give you a
second to guess an embankment so I mean
if you guessed that or not
but that's what was going on I saw
daddy's home - it's good enough it's
entertaining it's way more entertaining
than
flakes on a train or whatever that was
snake [ __ ] mystery train mystery with
Johnny Depp Orient Express better than
that it's not the directing was bad but
they you know it's fun to see it's fun
to see Mel Gibson Will Ferrell always
pretty good you know it was what it was
it's one of those movies where it's like
you know you know they're packing it
with stars you know just to get you into
the theater you know it's kind of like
one of those films it's just like the
way it is nowadays where you feel a
little bit taken advantage of every time
you go to the movies that's how I feel
every time I go I'm like why the [ __ ] am
I just coming back here it's based it's
to see a big screen I feel like I mean I
can't even remember um actually what's
the movie with a British movie Dunkirk
was the last really good movie that I
thought I saw but what else is going on
man oh KFC now KFC and that same for
Kentucky Fried Chicken they got that new
fried chicken bath bomb think about that
boy thinking about getting clean think
about getting clean and staying dirty at
the same time and this thing is finger
look you'll be finger licking clean dude
it's a KFC bath bombs you put that bath
bomb into the water and suddenly your
whole bathroom smells like KFC - you are
floating your chicken soup at that point
so I think that's sexy boy get you you
know you invite a lady over even if
y'all just roll up your pant legs and
stand in the tub of one of those going
off somebody's gonna pop a bit of an
erection or a you know a strong clitoris
you know and that is uh that can be
truly beautiful
so they got them KFC bath bombs if you
always wanted to have that you know that
luxurious chicken feeling wrapped around
your skin if it that if getting that
chicken in your stomach isn't enough you
want to be [ __ ] drowning in it then
you can do that nail wait till somebody
drowns in the [ __ ] that's what's gonna
happen
some schlubby muppet out
there with nine lips and you know zero
diplomas you know not even a GED you
know not even don't even own any just
know it doesn't even know to book that's
the people I don't I'm over you don't
know in a book you're out you're out
you're out you know that's like oh you
got to at least every nothing you should
have to read if you you should have to
do a book report that's one thing they
should still have us do as we get older
do a book report
oh you ever read a book in nine years ah
well guess what you're not allowed to
leave your house anymore because people
are over it but I saw that daddy's home
too
they got the new KFC bath bomb we got a
new producer today helping us out we're
on this producer realm right now this
producer this trial and air with the
producers so I'm girl I'm grateful to
that gentleman named Chris off the
internet so the Internet's powerful dude
you can get whatever you want off of
their drugs medium shirts you know you
can get that Canadian viagra make your
legs sweat son but that stuff will give
you that hitter you know but these days
can you even have an erection anymore
when do they shut that down you know
you're not gonna have any no man is
gonna be able to fly on an airplane dude
is it just me or is every dude on an
airplane erect every and Orani also on a
Greyhound bus sometimes even on a tram
if I got to go from B to F at the
Atlanta Airport I may pop that heat you
know what I'm saying I may build my own
upstairs between my legs dude made out
of skin and blood you know and wiener
parts because you will it's just there's
something about that airplane there's
something about that that tram that
jiggle in the machinery or something
makes your body start to salute the
universe with that bone with that bone
bone bone bone bone you know and I'll
tell this story I told this story before
but the first timer you know that you
know we were in the first time I saw
another man
bring his boner to the attention of a
group you know that wasn't a pervert was
when we were in the hot tub at this
boy's birthday party will the thrill'
and I've told this story before but I'm
gonna tell it again man because sometime
you got to let it go let it go like
who's that Disney girl Julie or
something I don't know what it is
whatever so this boy and we'll call him
TJ we'll Karam because I can't say his
real name but this boy TJ will care him
he was in a hot tub with us at a
birthday because the boy had a birthday
party and at the party they had a hot
tub in a hot tub basically in the south
it's just like it's basically I'm making
soup out of your family and it was in
the front yard and he had that hot tub
so while sitting in there feeling them
just feeling the joy of that hot tub and
that thing is just vibrating and you
know got the water and just really I
mean weird just a little damn crock-pot
of friends and uh big will Karen this
fella and his boy is about 30 years old
in the seventh grade or sixth grade I
mean he had a full mustache he I think
he had children and this dude was still
in school in this back when they keep
you in school forever and then
eventually they just made you a janitor
if you never graduated from you know
whatever grade it was we had two kids go
from class to janitor while I was in
school
this one black kid named mr. Larry
became a janitor and one other boy I
don't remember who he was though he
never said anything so and he wasn't
deaf or you know had sound issues he
just I think s he didn't have anything
to say you know he just wasn't real keen
on whatever was going on around him so
anyhow CJ was under the water in this
hot tub pleasuring himself you know just
petting that old uh you know petting
that old nut dolphin you know what I'm
saying that bone that Bam Bam Bam bang
tell me what you're gonna do so and then
next you know he stands up in the hot
tub and this is when this young fella
starts spraying out and we'd never seen
this we were children you
and this boy is just straight sup I ran
out you know just making fricking liquid
ghosts with his wiener into the air and
this one boy's house it was named will
the thrill' he thought that that TJ will
Karen was it basically leaking out of
his penis and was gonna dot like he was
gonna get smaller and smaller like
something's wrong like he had sprung a
leak
you know so he grabbed onto that dudes
boner to stop it from you know a jacket
and that's when CJ punched him in the
neck and I will never ever forget the
sound of that you never forget the sound
of somebody getting punched in the neck
when they are holding on to another
person's erection and nobody is gay in
the whole scenario so I'll never forget
that but anyhow welcome to Monday
November 27th of your life so I went and
saw daddy's home too and it was it was
mediocre at best and do you ever wonder
why we continue to get served up the
same cookie-cutter content you know or
how many times Hollywood can remake a
remake or how many new sequels can be
milked out of our favorite franchises I
do trust me we all do it's becoming
baffling it's becoming you go to the
theaters and you don't even expect the
movie to be good it's the incredible
power that the entertainment industry
has amassed is as I'll say it's it's
strangling creativity it's gotten too
big for its own britches
but finally we consumers can do
something about it and that something is
called live tree live tree is changing
the entertainment industry by creating a
new platform called adept the public
listen to me will be able to fund what
they want to watch own what they helped
produce and decide who's in it and what
goes on throughout the processes of
content creation funding and
distribution that means we can all
become producer just check it out live
tree dot-com imagine being able to help
create the amazing content that
want to see and be a part owner of it
now that's a possibility live tree
dot-com check it out I'm going to
alright I got I got some good calls that
came in this week man
not much has been on my mind you know
I've just been dealing with you know
some dating stuff and not wanting new uh
I think I think a lot this week I've
been thinking about a lot of like
there's not wanting to grow up man you
know just not wanting to grow up you
know I just don't want to do it I feel
like if I do certain things then I'm
giving up my youth you know I'm like
admitting that my childhood and that my
and I know my childhood is over I get
that I mean I must sound bad it's as I
listen to myself now it sounds crazy to
think that I'm even still thinking about
these things but it's just tough to want
to grow up man
you know it's tough to want to grow up
and it's hard and I think it's just that
we have a world out there now where it
feels like you don't have to a little
bit but it starts to look really weird
if you don't you know and I guess it
doesn't matter what it looks like to
other people and stuff like that but you
know you don't I don't want to end up
that old you know wrangled old man out
there you know driving around and laying
down in this truck and you know just
reading romance novels and all of that
[ __ ] and trying to do photography and
stuff at like 60 you know and just being
alone something not having any grandkids
I'm gonna pretend other people or other
people's kids grandkids or your
grandkids that's the weirdest [ __ ] ever
you know yeah these are my step
grandkids [ __ ] dude okay get your
own grandkids you know I just want us to
be doing all that so it just means I got
a you know get into a place where I
could settle down a little bit better
you know and get my mind right and get
my heart right and just grow up you know
sometimes you want to grow up and some
of it
about taking risk some fun I'm finding
you know it's about taking risks of like
getting into like headlong into a
relationship and being stable in it you
know I don't know there's just something
sometimes about giving up my Salah about
giving up my freedom that just scares me
I think I think that like if I give up
my ability to be free then I'm gonna be
I'm not gonna be in control of my life
or I'm not gonna be the only one in
control of my life you know like by
giving you know wholeheartedly into a
relationship and stuff that I will be
you know that I won't be the only one in
charge of my life then and that I guess
other times in my life when I did that
even times before I even knew I was
doing it you know probably relationships
from growing up as a child that I guess
it just didn't go well and so I think
there's like this innate part of me
that's kind of scared to do that but but
sometimes I guess that's the fear when
people say you just have to be brave and
just go against the fear you know you
just have to just know that something is
scary and then still go do it you know
and and the tough part is just when it's
something you've never done before you
know or it's like say if you touched a
fire when you were a baby or a child and
you and it burned you then you learn not
to but then as an adult you know there's
these fires out there that that they're
okay to touch you know they're not
necessarily bad but we just still you
know our skin and our insides and our
psyche still remember some of the burns
that we occur that that we incurred even
before we knew what it meant to like
reach out to a foot to a flame or
for we knew what a burn even was you
know because I think there are things
that happen to us when we're so young
that we that we just you know that we
don't remember but that our insides do
you know that are that are you know the
parts of us do you know anyhow I don't
want to get all deep you know into that
kind of stuff but that's just some stuff
that's been on my mind man it's just you
know being okay with growing up you know
and a lot of that is you know settling
down you know I've spent my money over
the years investing in different you
know real estate projects and things
like that here and there and part of me
doesn't you know it's like yeah I could
get a house but it's like do I want to
do that you know because all those
things get a dog you know you know have
a live-in girlfriend where maybe she
leaves her bra or something in the
hallway or it falls out of the laundry
basket and then you got a damn brassiere
in the hallway you know and those types
of things I just don't and you have
plants and you get plants and everything
together I don't know if I'm [ __ ]
shopping for damn basil with somebody
you know I'm not gonna be a co I'm not
gonna be you know I'm not going half in
on a damn bougainvillea with with a
woman you know I just won't if I'm doing
that but I think you have to do those
things to evolve because I do start to
find that I find myself spending in some
of the same circles and they're not bad
circles they're just comfortable circles
and if I stay comfortable then then I
don't then I fear that I won't get to
see everything that the world has to
offer or get to feel it you know and
some of those things include you know
having you know grandchildren when I'm
older you know cuz you gotta ya first
you have to have your own children
you can't magically just get
grandchildren dude unless you're a
pervert or a kidnapper you can't just
show up with [ __ ] grandchildren if
you never had children nobody's gonna
believe that [ __ ] you know some things
people will believe I got a hip
replacement other things people will not
believe like oh these are my grandkids
oh yeah Ronnie you never had kids maybe
you are a kidnapper Ronnie maybe you're
a pervert
so just thinking about that stuff but I
want to get into a couple of calls here
man we had some good ones dude I got to
tell you right now just so you know
what's coming up I had somebody take me
to task saying that I'm generalizing
black people so we're gonna get into
that I had somebody to say they been
pleasuring himself enira
they share a room with an animal and
they're dealing with some of that you
know how to how do you deal with a
self-pleasure
if you share a room with an animal I got
a UH we finally got our animal activists
we got a man out there you know our own
little dr. Dolittle and I had him I've
been hitting him up he hit the hotline
which is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three this beautiful
sweet gentleman I think he sound a
little bit Norwegian but he could be
something else
he hit the hotline and he had to choke
out a swan so he called it about choking
out a swan we got some callers are that
called in about dating and recovery
being blackout drunk and a couple of
other issues and then we got a topic for
next week we're gonna get into all that
right now first this gentleman this
gentleman called in from Portland and he
had some thoughts
let's hear him hey thank you for calling
brother man I appreciate it onward tell
you what to do or anything I'm just
gonna give you kind of my concerns about
it wait you're talking about it sounds
like I'm starting to generalize black
people and I'm not black myself but oh
come on man you sound a little black I
could see how that could piss off a
whole race I don't know I mean again I'm
not trying to tell you anything I'm not
a social justice blurrier you know I'm
not trying to say how you confront
let's - but it just sounds the general a
little bit and I think he's referring to
I know he's referring to do black people
do black men get nervous right and I
appreciate you calling man from Portland
you know the home of black people where
you had to get the two Portland
Trailblazers or you never would have
even had a black person probably around
probably within a hundred miles
I'm surprised they don't have black Darr
that it's an app in your area where you
even know if there's a black person
around I'm surprised that they didn't
have to have bring one up to the zoo at
some point so you guys could come and
see as an exhibit you know to get to
know some and look I I do appreciate
your calling right but I don't think
that I'm generalizing I think it's a
really good question do black people get
nervous because I've spent a good deal
amount well certainly my youth
surrounded by black people and I think
that that's fair for me too we all have
a hypothesis on anything you know and
people can talk about other races and
other cultures there's nothing wrong
with it I think it's probably I can
imagine it probably does make you
nervous if you live in a white centric
area you know that you that that would
make you nervous because you probably
have never really lived around some real
brothers and sisters you know I bet you
and I think you should try that go spend
some time down in New Orleans you know
go spend some time down there with you
know where they have real some real
black tivity going on you know where
things get wild you know there's so much
poverty that you know that crime is at
an all is at an unreal high in some
black areas you know where if you you're
afraid to even meet a black friend
because the odds of him living long
probably aren't very good I've had two
black friends killed in New Orleans in
the past decade killed as in knock knock
who's there
not them anymore so I you know it's just
a funny conversation
about and I think that it's okay man I
do appreciate you bringing it up though
could we be generalizing do black people
get nervous it's not a damn scientific
study but I think it's a unique and rare
question and we also asked black people
to call in and comment because the first
the first bachelor called as we got it
was way too many whites you know and we
wanted to vibe it out a little bit but
look man I'd love for you to come down
to Louisiana go out to you know a place
where there's a really good mix of
diversity and just check it out I do
appreciate your call and we'll listen to
the rest of it here we go to make it
funny I guess that's one way to talk
about it and given my telling you what
you should you don't just I giving you
my thoughts about the generalization of
a human race I mean that's kind of a
piss off in black I think anyone when
I'm generalized that's what pisses off
these blacks that's hilarious
I mean that's a that seems ridiculous to
me but I'll say this man I think the I
think someone who has no real comfort
around a culture is somebody that I
think thinks every everything up they
anytime you bring up something about
them that it's generalizing or it's mmm
you know that it's that it's
stereotyping or that it's you know I
think you just got to get out and spend
time a little bit more at least hang out
with a zebra start there because he was
the best thing was I I had people that
called in about the topic who were black
bro and half black that means part black
part something else that's crazy that's
like a Rubik's Cube dude in your soul
and nobody complained I just don't like
it when people complain for [ __ ] that
they're not you know like
had this group one time water for the
blind the blind what
there was no blind people out there at
the water for the blind event and I've
never seen a dry blind I've never seen a
dry blind person and my cousin's blind
dude and only you know what he says he
says it's not that bad in there so what
do you say to that we're all out here
guesstimating you know while he's
sitting in there living in some free
meditation in his mind at times you know
it is a little bit of a social justice
well we're generalizing you know and I'm
sorry it isn't it's not a little not
fair I mean it pick at you like that
since this is a one-sided conversation
because it's not a live call but I just
think I think I appreciate your point
man let's hear a call from a black guy
whoa you may want to check with your
with your with your parents out there if
you can even hear this call guy or pull
over I don't want you to get nervous
having a black guy come to your stereo
speakers here we go yeah how you doing
Theo this is Jacob big fan honestly I
don't think black people get nervous me
being a half black man other Hassocks
panics I think we get more anxiety if
anything interesting so more anxiety
than nerves onward nerves don't have a
play a big role in that
but then how did definitely there
honestly I think the only time I've ever
been nervous is in a crowd for the white
people just to be honest but that's
probably just for just because being
judged and not nerves you know but as
far as that I don't think I've ever seen
another black man getting nervous yeah
and that's one of the things that made
me even think of this topic in the
beginning because I never had you know
I'm not I'd never seen it I'd never seen
that I could remember a nervous black
guy
like I mean I think there's some instant
like actually I was skydiving one time
with a black friend and he got nervous
so now that I really start thinking
about it yes there's one instance but on
a regular in instances where I would get
nervous my black friends never seemed to
I don't mean to interrupt you let's hear
more yeah but uh definitely you know we
have a lot of pride and we've built
walls around us and we have thick skin
so there you go they got thick skin man
that's that thick skin you know like
that girl that had in my time with that
thick skin but yeah I mean it could be
something that that you know with such
we've talked about this before and we're
gonna move on because I know we've
gelled on this before but it's an
obviously an interesting topic and so I
don't think and here's the thing if we
don't if we can't talk about it if
everything's a generalization if anytime
that a white guy brings up or anything
rate and that has to do with a race it's
looked at as a generalization I think
that that's that's not a good deal I
think it's just not a safe place to be
and especially because we got at if
we're not comfortable talking our world
is hiding behind things we want to
questions we want to ask then what are
we just for like a Muppet man and I need
me to you know get loud at you there
mister Oregon but I mean Portland ain't
a real hotbed for brothers and sisters
up there okay I don't see you guys you
know I'll see you guys uh won't you guys
um build a tunnel from there to East st.
Louis and help help out some of the
impoverished over there you know you're
living out there in a real safe zone
clean water how about that clean water
y'all drinking y'all up there sipping it
you know being white as hell anyhow we
got some good topics man and this is a
question let's take this next call and
man I guess I got under my skin a little
bit I don't know why now I guess I got
under my skin because I just don't think
that's generalizing man do black people
get nervous no that's something that
want to know and that's something that's
fun to ask and I think that those are
those are fun things that we should be
able to ask about each other is how the
[ __ ] I'm ever gonna know huh
how in the [ __ ] am I ever gonna know if
I can't open up my mind and I wasn't
just asking White's dude it wasn't a
secret meeting it wasn't a cooker cook
question all right let's keep it moving
dude here we go we got this call came in
right here now this guy and this fella
had something on his mind and this is
interesting here we go hey what's up
Theo my name is Adam and got a little
question for you maybe get your thoughts
on a little well something some in the
dark arts
now here's Adam Colin thank you for
calling this Eve Venning see what I did
there Adam in evening okay pretty bad
here we go
Thanks calling at him that I've been
thinking about and kind of doing so oh
can I even think about these dark arts
and you've been doing them as well huh
so you a dark artiste already you know
you out there you already uh you know
van Gogh in deep let's go I'm going on
my fifth year of marriage and my wife at
about year two informed me that watching
pornography was akin to cheating okay so
your wife thinks watching pornography is
akin to cheating homeward and so she
requested that I stop watching that
pornography and so I did but what she
did for me was she allowed me to start
filming us doing the nasty
oh okay boy so you Danny say he's
starting up your own deal there huh that
freaking uh you starting to do a little
bit of directing huh suddenly you got a
couple of new headlamps on the bed huh
you got into some new a new light kit in
the corner of the bedroom come more us
making that sweet love and that's got me
through you know it got me it gets me
through those you know those dry spells
you run into when you're married but uh
so anyway the dark arts part of this
comes in with me I kind of want to try
something else
and I'm not sure on how she's gonna take
it but mmm so you got you and your wife
she wants you off to pornography now you
doing the video collage you know you
make it a little uh you know Memory
Tapes
oh god this is getting good this is like
a UH like riding on the bus or on the
tram - all of a sudden I feel like I'm
on a plane if you know what I'm saying
okay more I kind of want to film her
banging somebody else ooh
so you want to film your wife catching a
little bit of that sweet Dee Weiner from
somebody else hear more and may sound
weird to some people it may sound you
know the the jealous type you know they
they wouldn't get into something like
that but I've been thinking about it a
lot man and you know even sometimes when
my wife is doing nasty things to me I
kind of in my head start thinking like
I'm somebody else
like she's doing it to somebody else and
it kind of kind of flips my switch you
know what I mean Wow
so even when your wife's doing things to
you that's wild and that's naughty you
know and she gives you know she building
up she you know she putting something
special in your gingerbread you know
that you imagine that somebody that
she's doing it to somebody else that's
cool dude it's interesting man you know
really this is getting really
interesting let's hear more I feel like
I'm wandering into a castle right now
and you know into a part of a castle I'm
not supposed to be at you know like
everybody's eating dinner in one room
and I was in there and then I wandered
off to look for the restroom and I can't
find it and now I'm just kind of
wandering into rare rooms let's hear
more but uh anyway man I'd like to know
your thoughts on that you know is asking
her to do that or eventually maybe even
getting her to do that what you think
had a kind of an effect it might have on
the old marriage Wow Wow Wow we wha well
look man out I've been lying if it's
haven't thought about this that I
thought about that if I were married you
know am I gonna be able to not act out
outside of my marriage and be sensual
you know we're trying to be sensual with
other women at times or get affected by
that I think you know because a lot of
men they worried that's a regular worry
of men I've talked to other men about
this who are married it's a regular
worry of men and so then you start to
think your brain will start to think
well how can I make it work in my
marriage you know obviously if I'm gonna
step out then the only thing that would
be fair would be the first to say to my
wife well you can step out or you know
Gary can step in to your cooter or
something like that so you know you
because you want to make it even you
want to make it an even deal so that
I've thought about those things you know
I've already played that out in my head
well then you think about you being back
in the kitchen two days later with your
wife you know and you know y'all having
a couple she pours a cup of lemonade and
she says you want some and usually you
would take the lemonade and have a sip
out of her cup but suddenly I'm like
where's this mouth man you know is they
got a little bit of Gary on the edge of
this cup and those are my thoughts when
my brain starts rambling you know if I'm
to get into those situations so that's
wild you know I've done some I've had
some directorial debuts in the bedroom
back in the day and did a little bit of
recording of sex and watching sex you
know rewatching it you know to get you
fired up the tapes are never great
you know but I think the memories
sometimes kind of are but then you have
that tape out there so at a certain
point you have to burn that tape or get
rid of it because you're worried about
it being out there but I'm gonna propose
this question to our listeners what do
you think it's a two-parter and you can
answer this one part if you want because
I don't really have the best information
for you because I'm not married and I
haven't been in that situation but is
pornography cheating do you feel like it
is I personally feel like pornography is
it's kind of cheating you know in small
doses it's not but if it's a habit and
it's a bad habit then you are taking
away that Chi that lust that is supposed
to be you know between you and your
partner you're taking that out of the
equation and [ __ ] you everything else is
going to be shitty if you ain't trying
to catch that nut locally with your lady
so that's one part is porn cheating
second part is what do you think about
that about having another man come into
the household and you know pleasure your
lady and do that and I know they call it
there's a cooking or something other
some term up for it out there but I want
to know if there's men out there or
married who have had this conversation
or have had this come into their
marriage they don't need to leave their
name if they want when they call or if
there's women out there who have
experimented with this or their men's
have asked them this and what happened
there what occurred because if you hear
I'm saying they only got so much room in
the garage you know and maybe that'll
get you fired up I mean I could see that
you know one thing that makes them oh
you know a man attracted to his spouse
is that they that they are other men
could be attracted to her so maybe
that's an element of it but that's while
dude you know yeah hey look you you are
you are you should be a tour guide of
the dark hearts brother because you'd
out there you stepping on a lot of
different stones you're stepping on a
lot of different stones up there at dark
arts castle but thank you for calling
man I appreciate it and that it's gonna
be our topic for Thursday guys if you'll
hit the hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and
let me know and let that call or no
right there let me see his name again
hey what's up do my name is Adam and let
Adam know what you think about that is
pornography cheating that's what his
wife thinks and then if he lets a man in
a you know cater to his wife's buffet
you know to hit her up in that little
sweet wallet you know to catch that you
know that wild canal and he's gonna be
videotaping and how's that gonna play
out have you ever done that advice for
him or let's keep it cruising there here
we go we got another caller right here
on the hotline
this is Derek calling from New York City
hey Derek New York City the land of
coked-up taxi drivers and woman who may
be mad yep the landed coked up taxi
drivers and women who maybe me and I've
been involved with at least one of those
had a little argument with my girlfriend
less my parents got involved in all of
that and basically all boiled down to
that I I need therapy I need to go to
therapy
so basically what I'm asking is just how
do you deal with the fear of your
therapist about the difference what just
what you've experienced that you find
difficult to talk about with people that
you meet every day okay and his call
kind of cuts out right there it was just
a connection issue but I'm gonna restate
it for you is how do you deal with
telling your therapist you know the dark
things and you know things that you you
know you don't just tell people every
day I think for one to take some getting
used to you know I see a therapist once
a week and I don't not go there are
times when I feel like not going to the
therapist and I've been instructed
that's when you go because your brain
will tell you don't go to the therapist
you're fine
well that's the same brain that is not
fine you know a sick brain isn't going
to is not going to get you well so you
have to have some help
and I'm a proponent of therapy you know
I've gone most of this year I think it's
getting better there's days where that's
nothing happens in there and then
there's days where you know I really get
in touch with something in my past or in
my life that you know really hindered me
and I'm able to you know melt it down a
little bit melt down some of that ice
you know that iceberg it's helped me a
lot with family relationships and stuff
like that and to recognize my part in
certain things but I appreciate you call
a man and I know that this is something
you know it sounds like this is
something that's pretty real to you and
I'm glad that you're trying to get some
help because that's because you can you
can get better you can and that's what's
one thing that I'd love for you to know
is that there were times when I thought
I'm not going to get better you know I'm
gonna be the same you know I'll never be
honest in a relationship I'll never be a
caring person I mean I used to think
about having children I couldn't never
even imagine it imagine it I thought I
was crazy anybody had kids if anybody
got married I thought it was crazy I
didn't go to one of my best friends
weddings growing up because I thought it
was absolutely erroneous but now because
of therapy I can actually imagine some
of those things and that's that's
different that's a change you know to
actually be able to imagine something
that before you completely rejected I
mean that's an actual change I mean I
strongly believe that a leopard can't
change its spots it but it does take
some work and if you get scared to talk
about some things I would tell the
person there are some things that I'm
scared to talk to you about I would be
really really honest if you feel like
they're not a good therapist I would
tell them why but not in a mean way you
know I remember telling my therapist I
feel like you don't care about me one
time and she had to assure me that she
did care
and uh and it took that step for things
to get a little bit better between us
you know you don't have to always agree
with your therapist you know your goal
is just to be in there and to try not to
run the show that those are only things
that I can recommend and also try
different therapist if you need to go to
two or three the first week try them
each out insurance usually will help you
know and if you get afraid just remember
that other people have done it and
you're just as capable as those other
people and no matter what you have
inside you that you're afraid to tell
you're gonna be okay you know you really
will because people that love you and
care about you are gonna people that
really do I'll tell you this man I've
had to tell some people some things and
they still love and care about you they
really do so I think you got this man
and yeah I'm gonna go to my therapist
tomorrow so if you have to go this week
or if you had to go out you know Hopi I
hope you do just go just go start there
go share and just try not to you know if
you get in a tough spot call somebody
you know or just tell your therapist how
you're feeling you know it's okay to
tell them you don't you can tell me you
don't think are a good therapist
sometimes that's the thing we need to
explore is how we behave towards other
people you know but you can get better
man if you need to give it a shot I'm
proud of you bro keep your head up all
right let's cruise some more and thank
you for calling I'm calling because I
have a girlfriend you see how excited
God sounded man dudes are having trouble
with this kind of stuff let's hear more
Gus thank you for calling
get blackout drunk and Tim to be a dick
to her and I don't really know why I
don't know
just call me get that off my chest I
guess thank ya cool yep you get blackout
drunk and you're a dick to your
girlfriend that's probably a lot of
America does that you know why do they
do it I mean the reason why I would do
it before was because I was just
controlling you know I used to do that
in high school I think it's in in
college you know just it was a
controlling type behavior you know and I
you know I felt like I wasn't really
that person that's why we get drunk and
do it you know because in the real
person I was probably wanted to care
about her but instead I'm like oh well
let's just get blackout drunk and be
mean to her you know cuz it probably was
afraid to be you know just real you know
I was probably just afraid to sit there
and be sober and just tell her either
that I cared or that I didn't care you
know I was afraid to be real you know
it's easy to just get drunk and do
whatever then it's not or even your
responsibility oh I was drunk well go
out go out with her one night sober see
how you feel
do you even like her do you like being
around her you know do you love her
[ __ ] maybe you love her do that could be
scary you know see how you treat her
whenever you're not drinking I think
that's probably a better barometer of
how you really feel about her you know
maybe if you're able to share some of
the ways you feel about her and it gets
some of that you know confusion out of
you then maybe you won't even be you
know getting drunk and and being rude to
her those are just some thoughts that I
have you know I'm getting I never really
liked getting blackout drunk and I never
even really did it actually I mean I
would get pretty drunk and then I would
wet the bed and that at a certain point
you kind of quit doing that because you
just don't want to change your sheets
anymore so
but you know what I'm saying Gang Gang
boy
keep it together ma'am I appreciate you
calling and if you find yourself getting
blackout drunk a lot cuz blackout drunk
is a real thing maybe check out an AAA
meeting you know I'm not saying a is for
you only you know that but I'll tell you
this dude if you still getting blackout
drunk a year from now and yelling at
your girlfriend I don't see how that
ends well overall you might end up on
the episode of Dateline NBC I'm Lester
Holt and this is a you know murder
blackout and and blackout and bludgeoned
in Seattle or whatever all right let's
take another call thank you for your
call the vulnerable baby you know what
I'm saying that's a worsening name the
vulnerable I have a friend named Ronnie
ship and he was in that OJ Simpson
documentary and he was the kind of
light-skinned black man who was a police
officer back in the day who was friends
with OJ and the only person that
testified only friend of OJ's that
testified against him during his first
trial and his name is Ron and we call
him the ronimal and I love that name
dude onward a CJ and hey Dallas I love
Dallas man I love Dallas Texas
everything's big down there a big fan
for for a [ __ ] wild eye man anyways
here's my thing I'm 22 and I go to
university I'm seeing this new girl I'm
out of a two and a half year
relationship and then seeing this girl
for about a week and a half two weeks
things are things great connection man
this girl I swear to god she's out of my
league Wow congratulations man maybe
she's not out of your league man maybe
just didn't recognize what league you
were in you know but I'm glad to know
that you have somebody that you're
interested in that feels that feels good
let's hear more but she's smart she's
super sexy she's a sweetheart and we
vibe connect really
well with that being said CEO I'm I
mentioned this to you when I saw you I'm
in recovery
I was and I'm an addict
I was addicted to opiates for two years
namely heroin and I'm calling to ask
what is your opinion on sharing that
information with someone new that you're
seeing a part of me doesn't want to
mention a teller at all effort I also
think that maybe after three four months
however long and they need to feel like
I can trust her then maybe it'd be
beneficial to add her to my already
existing support system that is helping
me in my recovery well man I appreciate
it man I appreciate this call yeah you
know it's not like you got one on the
hook you got a live one you know you got
a live one and I I had diarrhea one time
during a fishing tournament that Randy
Moss put on up there on Lake Minnetonka
and I had to be in a fishing rodeo and I
had to meet up with a couple of men
early one morning at 6:00 a.m. and one
of them was a professional angler and I
don't know if you've ever held that
diarrhea in your body for five hours on
a bass boat but no way that man was a
more professional angler than I was by
the end of that day I mean dude we had a
couple in the live well at the end of
that day live fish I had about I
probably had 2,000 in the live well of
my body so praise God but I'm gonna say
this to you man congratulations on your
sobriety congratulations sticking with
your recovery and staying steadfast
that's cool dude getting off heroin I
can't I can't even imagine that I can't
even imagine that because one heroin
seems awesome and two I know I just hear
that it's a really really tough thing to
kick so kudos to you finding love in
your life that could be something you
probably never thought would happen to
you before you know but I'll say this to
you man I didn't know what to answer
here so I texted a friend of mine who's
in the program who's been in longer than
me because that's something that I learn
through my own recovery and this was his
answer because that's one thing that
that I learn about in and my 12-step
program is that if I don't know then I
ask somebody who has more experience
than me and it's because otherwise I'll
just make a choice that's ill-advised
and this is this was his quote man
someone's gonna read it to you if he's
planning to just [ __ ] then don't tell
don't tell her if you think the person
is special then right away in my opinion
that's what my friend said he said it's
only his opinion now because there are
no rules to this also use your intuition
you can also pray for guidance and let
it go your voice sounds like you have
some clarity and some you're in who you
are I know that speculation but let's be
honest dude it sounds pretty clear so I
think you probably can trust your
instincts always let go and leave it in
God's hands if you don't know what to do
you know that's the serenity prayer we
know that
and one more nugget the foundation of a
relationship is built on trust someone
tells me upfront that they are in
recovery and working on being the best
version of oneself that goes a long way
if it's kept from me until later and
that could be a little bit fishy be
upfront and let go because that's a
heavy yoke again that's only an opinion
but I second that's my buddy bill and I
second that opinion man a second you
know trust your instincts feel it out
don't feel the pressure to tell or cuz
sometimes you can you know start the own
avalanche on your side and suddenly you
have to but you know feel it out see how
it's going go on another date or two if
she isn't pressuring or anything you
know sometimes I say I go to a men's
group that's what I say I don't even say
AAA I said I go to a men's group because
being around other successful healthy
men is only gonna make me a successful
and healthy man that's what I say
sometimes but it's uh but it's a it's a
cool spot to be in the cool spot to be
in do you got a little sobriety on one
arm you got a little dime piece on the
other boy
and let me tell you this even if it
doesn't work out with her dude I have a
feeling you have great things in store
for your future I really believe that
thank you for your call man you know you
get out there and hug that lady hug that
Swan
speaking of hugging a swan you like that
you like that segue my boy big bowed
ralt is out there and he called the head
and it is the animal rights act
activists they're not even an activist
just animal activists this dude's out
there [ __ ] with animals and he work
with animals out there checking animals
and feeling animal eggs and stuff in the
wilderness and in the wild out there but
you know I'll put out there am on mother
nature's back strap you know he's out
there feeling around you know up around
mother nature's clavicle and he got an
issue with a swan let's hear it out here
we go thank you for calling brother your
animal man calling to share that story
about having a choked up that's one
Alaska animal man thanks for calling
animal man let's go more oh it's a
survival situation every time you if
it's chill got a sofa on brah you know
what I'm saying the only people ever to
do it I think a you and Billy Madison
let's hear more not a hostage situation
and we were supposed to get a food drop
like in a waterproof bag I'm going to
figure out their three weeks and halfway
through a plane was with the fly over
and drop a bag of food and the pilot
[Music]
damn well you got [ __ ] in the back son
onward thank you for this call is as
interesting so you're supposed to get a
food drop and now a food drop that's
when you have a plane that's dropping
off food that's simple basically says is
what it says almond doing a thing so
yeah the pilot couldn't get down low he
had to drop the bag from twice as high
up and the bag hit the river we were on
exploded all the food washed down the
river de Mayo sorry for laughing dude
but sometimes I love and [ __ ] like that
happens
one time somebody threw a pool ball you
know like a eight ball from a pool table
but it was an 11 ball
somebody threw it down the street and it
hit this dude right in the leg and you
couldn't hear it at all but the dude was
in so much pain and I laughed sometimes
[ __ ] like that is just funny but
watching people lose a week and a half
worth of food into a river
yeah that's up there I went and we had
to just feel really good so we showed a
lot of growth we were making our way
down the river everything was going fine
eating a lot of spruce grouse and rough
grouse a few geese you hopped up on that
grouse huh what you know in that grouse
oh wait and then we're running out of
bullets and it was one of the last days
and I came around the bend and a group
of swans trumpeter swans which are
threatened I think it sounds like you
got one play in the cello right there
with you now
Oh word so I shot one in the back and
he's had a swan in the back how many
years a bad luck is that more the rest
of them flew off and that was the last
bullet our shotgun show we had so I ran
up to the thing I was alone and once you
get up to him they're a lot bigger than
you really expect so the thing started
hissing at me and beat me with its wings
and I grabbed on us next thinking I
could just choke it out say good night
but the things neck is like a vacuum
hose it's really really thick and it was
really beating me up for the band this
is so crazy
so you choking us falling out and it's
beating you up more I've had the turnip
head around and around the room eight it
wasn't that good even pretty tough kind
of muddy taste but um you ever eaten
wild meat and he rode me you found on
the side of the road we part of an
anaconda we found in Argentina that was
still moving a little bit that wasn't
that good either
anyway liked your Keurig coffee rent
that isn't [ __ ] that's basically
hunt work much water alright animal man
thank you for calling in he's gonna call
in other times as well that's a real
story from animal man calling out of
that Costa Rica and be well down there
man I know you down there checking out
the animals and making sure that kingdom
Animalia is running 100 you know running
that top-notch you know because
sometimes you know mother nature needs a
little bit of a needs a little helper
just like santa need helpers some time
to build those little wooden trains and
stuff some time mother nature needs a
helper to go out there and touch a swan
or you know to [ __ ] choke a duck out
or to pet a deer you know where to you
know where to you know bottle feed a
porcupine like you see on Facebook
sometimes you know or sometimes people
you know mother nature needs assistance
and it's good to see you out there you
know doing some amazing work man so
thank you for that dude damn you [ __ ]
SWAT you shot a swan in the back yo that
[ __ ] don't end well and I've never had
Swan mean I've had some dove I've had a
little bit of dove a couple brothers was
grilling up a dove one time and that was
out there outside of Natchez Mississippi
and I copped a little bit of food with
them I denied I'm they invited me a
couple days to eat with him to break
dove and finally I gave him man and had
to be a little D you know I had to break
a little dove with a couple of honestly
black men sorry to say it I don't want
to scare anybody up in Oregon but these
were black guys what what what happened
I'm sorry man because I do want this
there's definitely a place for callin
look man I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about this is place for anybody
call and disagree in this and that you
know but don't tell me what air is like
if you only lived in water you know
that's my thing
you know and I
so I looked here if you got thoughts on
that you guys let me know on that too
am I being ridiculous in my generalizing
maybe I am generalizing maybe I live in
a time it doesn't even exist anymore in
my brain where a man can say something
without thinking like everything he says
is wrong we're taking one last call here
we're gonna stick on this animal topic
we've had a good it's been a fun episode
man it's been cruising nine eight five
six six four nine five two zero three is
the hotline you can hit it and I want
you guys to I hit it by Wednesday we'll
be putting together the episode
Wednesday evening for for is porn
cheating and would you invite another
man to be in the bedroom to see your
wife and and look sometimes your first
thought might be no I wouldn't or that's
the thought I'm gonna put on the call
but I want you to be real you know I
mean I admitted to you I've daughter if
I get married now and if I have to get
out you know I want to if I want to
circumvent the rules of my marriage how
would I do it or I would have to be
partisan I would have to go be part you
know allow my wife the same or discuss
it with her first obviously but then
what you know and then I'm really gonna
be okay with that when some man coming
jousting you know some man trolling
Wiener and my wife it makes you wonder
but we're gonna stick with this animal
wah we're gonna stick with this animal
thing right here man I think actually
I'm gonna all right here we go this is
hey my name is John I'm from Northern
California but I just moved up here to
Washington Oh John from Northern
California to Washington middle of
nowhere and I just moved over into this
house and there was a dog here and we
became quick friends and my friend okay
so you got a new dog for a new friend
that's a dog okay this sound like life's
going well for you and you got a new
friend that's an animal
and that's better than people these days
sometimes onward pretty quickly you know
and I don't that means best buddies you
know I mean I appreciate what you're
saying but I don't know if that's best
buddies necessarily but let's hear more
but today I was in the room and I kind
of wasn't really thinking anything of it
but after I directed like the dog was
just just growl at me
and it still girl man every time I tried
going like giving me give him some
scratches give him some love like I do
well yeah buddy I'm gonna stop you there
John I appreciate the call you know of
course the dog don't want to spend time
with you if you've been masturbating by
it and I don't blame it you know it
probably looked at what happened when
you're touching yourself and your body's
spraying out you know like that boy CJ
will care him in that spa in that
whirlpool and it's probably thinkable if
he touches me is the same thing that
happen to me you know I'm not just gonna
start spitting up in the yard so that's
probably some of what's going on brother
so I wouldn't you know I think you need
to just relax a little bit you know
maybe steer clear of animal give him a
little bit of space you just jerked off
next to him so won't you give him a
little bit of room in his life man but
thank you guys for being with me this
week man thank you guys for being all
all with me we've been growing man
things are going good I want to thank
sure for the editing Chris we got a
producer stopped in today and we got and
we got our our patreon errs and and
thank you guys so much everybody happy
belated Thanksgiving we're moving into
Christmas we're still getting some
things out of our system at the end of
the year hit the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three bless
everybody that's getting in a recovery
or going through those things or making
any effort to make their life different
or better or to try something new
and bless us all figure it all out as we
continue to learn you know I mean I'm
just trying to not kill myself or others
while I continue to learn that's gonna
be my goal for this week so keep your
head up be good to yourself because you
probably deserve it and I'll see you
guys I'll see you guys I think on
Thursday we'll get this Thursday episode
up and shout out to grey block pizza
always you know go to grey block that's
on Pico Boulevard Los Angeles get that
hitter y'all be good
[Music]
celebrate